[موسيقى]
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي يكشف عن خلل في
تفعيل منظومه القبه الحديديه في جوله
القتال الاخيره مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وبحسب معلومات الجيش الاسرائيلي فان القبه
الحديديه اعترضت في عمليه سيف القدس
661 صاروخا من اصل ثلاثه
الاف3300 صاروخ
و735 صاروخا من اصل اربعه الاف وخمسمائه
واربعه وتسعين صاروخا
و428 صاروخا اطلق من قطاع غزه من اصل 1500
صاروخ في عمليه حجاره السجن
لكن العوده الى دعاوى التعويض التي قدمت
خلال العمليات العسكريه تعطي نظره اقرب
الى فاعليه القبه الحديديه مع نهايه عمليه
سيف القدس في مايو ايار عام 2021
يتضح ان الاسرائيليين في المناطق
المستهدفه بصواريخ المقاومه تقدموا بنحو
5830 دعوه تعويض عن الخسائر الماديه التي
اصابت ممتلكاتهم منها اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
وثلاثمائه دعوى اضرار في المباني وما يزيد
على 2200 دعوه اضرار في السيارات وقرابه
170 دعوه اضرار اخرى لتبلغ قيمه الاضرار
بالممتلكات نحو 55 مليون دولار هذا عدا عن
الخسائر الاقتصاديه الاخرى نشر نظام القبه
الحديديه للمره الاولى نهايه 2011
يديرها سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي نشرت بدايه
بالقرب من قطاع غزه وتوسع الدائرتها لاحقا
لتشمل نشرب بطاريات قرب عسقلان واشدود
وجنوبه الاديب ومدينه تيفود الواقعه على
مسافه 20 كيلومترا من حدود غزه وتبلغ قيمه
صاروخ تنير الواحد المستخدم في عمليه
الاعتراض نحو 50 الف دولار
[موسيقى]